how are you spreading the word about the
film I know right now you said your kind
of you seem like you're at a peace with
it you have it on the side and they
believe that if sort of the the teacher
is ready the student work will appear in
terms of finding the film and the
message but how are you are you working
on spreading it through social media or
doing anything like that yeah what's
like you know the whatever the current
kind of like the hot almost like Twitter
or Facebook or the website itself even
Google in its own just like looking up
something the movie would come up I mean
all that stuff is really made it I don't
say made it easier for filmmakers but
you definitely have an outlet because
when we were making the movie there was
nothing except a distributor that you
had I mean you literally had to find a
distributor otherwise don't even bother
to make your movie but now you don't
even need a distributor and if a
distributor comes along great and if you
don't have a distributor you have access
to the audience and you know when like
that the Elizabeth the producer that you
you know you know Elizabeth she's she's
just very good at like taking care of
Twitter and and I'm not very good at it
I'm just not I'm not very good at
spreading the word I guess I'm spreading
the word now is it hard for you to be
self-promotional I know a lot of artists
have that I just don't know how to do it
you know I don't know how to do it I
guess because you're always busy
thinking about something else or you're
shooting something you know it's so
you're it takes it's not an easy thing
to actually follow up spread the word
that's why I think like elizabeth is
much better than me because I just don't
know how to I don't know how to keep it
moving so that's why I think also with
projects especially like when you have a
whole movie you can't have one person
like also doing everything and then you
think you're also gonna do like you're
gonna spread the word on the film it's
not easy you just really have to have
more of a game plan to like you know
whether it's you and your partner or a
couple of people are three people or
four people you have to like break it
down and go you're gonna run with this
I'm gonna do that and I think it makes
it more accessible and you have to know
what you're doing so it's like I'm not
very good I mean I'm good with the
internet but we're spending the word I
think she's much better than me so if
one of you is good at something I think
they should just take care of it
themselves sure
you